unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are
influencing the news you read download
the ground news app for free
at davidpakman.com ground of the people
is a new platform matching local
campaigns with supporters and donors
from across the country
sort of like a yelp for local candidates
you can filter by policy and location
and you can support the next generation
of leaders check it out at of the
people.us
all right let's start today with a
weekly coronavirus update
it does seem increasingly like what we
said last week might be going on
is going on which is that the plateau
in the decline in cases and deaths that
we saw last week was not really a
plateau it wasn't really
a reversal it was an artifact
of the storms in much of the country
which slowed down
testing and vaccination i'll explain
in more detail but let's just jump right
into the numbers starting with cases
of course on january 11th we saw the
average
peak of daily cases hit 250
55 000 cases per day a number
that a year ago would have been
inconceivable when dr fauci said
we might get to a hundred thousand cases
a day so many people saying no we won't
and we got to an average of 255 000
cases a day as of january 11th
but then we saw a reverse and the
numbers started to decline and we saw
average case numbers go below 200
000 a day below 150 000 a day below a
hundred thousand a day
down to about seventy thousand cases a
day and then around february nineteenth
twentieth the decline appeared to stop
case numbers even went up a few days now
my idea was
this is not a real increase this is
because of the bad weather in the united
states
why would that be the storms that push
texas into blackout conditions right
around
mid-february led to lower than
actual numbers being reported for some
time so the decline we saw in
mid-february
was bigger than reality because a lot of
testing was being delayed
at the end of february as testing got
caught up
we were getting more cases reported than
the real number of new cases
as the backlog tests were processed so
yesterday was the day
with the fewest cases since october 13th
right around 52 000 cases and i believe
that that's the real number i think
there was a period between january 11th
and yesterday
where numbers were artificially low and
then a period where numbers were
artificially high i think that the
backlog has been cleared
and we're now back to sort of the real
numbers one example
a friend of mine's dad was tested
around february 15th it took 11 days to
get the results
that he tested positive he's doing fine
he's actually vaccinated and has no
symptoms whatsoever
that is a positive test that should have
shown up far earlier but because of the
delays
that didn't show up until february 28th
so bottom line
cases from the peak on january 11th down
73 percent that's a great number we're
closing in on getting below 50 000 a day
that would be
an important milestone now in terms of
deaths a very similar trajectory deaths
peaked
at about 3 400 a day on january 26th
from that point deaths are down 42
we saw a similar bump right as the
storms passed and the data
normalized there is no doubt that 1900
deaths a day which is where we are now
is outrageous but if you have outrageous
tragic numbers
that are going down you prefer that to
outrageous tragic numbers that are going
up
another important statistic that we
track are hospitalizations
good news there is that hospitalizations
are down from a peak of more than
hundred and thirty thousand
just after uh the start of 2021
down from 130k to about 52 000
hospitalizations
that's a hospitalization decline of
about 60 percent
as more and more high-risk people get
vaccinated
that number should decline more now the
really exciting news if there's anything
exciting at all to look at
in the midst of horrible tragedy that's
coming from vaccines we now have a third
vaccine
given an emergency use authorization
this is the johnson johnson
vaccine it is a one dose vaccine
now there are people who were negative
on this vaccine
saying oh it's less efficacious than the
pfizer and
modern vaccines and there are three
important things to consider there
number one
the johnson and johnson vaccine even if
less effective at preventing infections
appears to be just as good as the other
vaccines at preventing
serious covid and keeping people out of
hospitals all right so
number one that's very important number
two
it's only one dose meaning that given x
number of doses
if you have five million jnj doses you
can vaccinate 5 million people rather
than just 2.5 million if you had that
same number of pfizer
or modernity doses because it's one dose
only
and number three it's not actually clear
that the jnj vaccine really is not as
good at preventing infection now i know
the headlines
are often pfizer moderna 95
effective jnj only 65 70
there are studies these are still
pre-prints so take everything with with
some skepticism
now but there are studies that suggest
that because the jnj phase 3 trials
were tested on the variants that we're
so worried about including the south
africa variant
that the lower number the 65 70 percent
reflects the variance and that if you
were to do the pfizer and moderna trials
with the variants you would also be
seeing 65
70 so the point is it's not really clear
jnj is less effective
get whatever vaccine is available and
we had a very good three-day period this
past weekend
friday saturday sunday where almost
7 million doses were injected over the
three days 6.9 million doses in fact
so we are now averaging 1.8 million
doses a day
joe biden wanted to do a million a day
for a hundred days
we might be able to double that we might
be able to more than double it we we
could even be getting to 2.5
or 3 million doses a day regularly soon
as there are massive dumps of vaccine
doses
coming in march realistically it
it's conceivable that the problem by the
end of this month
will be do we have enough vaccination
sites
and vaccinators to inject all of the
doses that we're going to have
some locations probably need to start
thinking about ramping up
to 24 7 vaccination that's a good
problem to have
assuming you can solve it we want to
make sure that we can uh use
all of the doses that we're getting so
things are looking up
it's a race against the variants it's
again a race against people behaving
less carefully
because of the good news but uh i i
continue to be cautiously optimistic
we'll check in again in another week
send me your thoughts about what's going
on locally with vaccines where you live
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
after the break
we're going to talk about cancel
culture yes it's the right's new
obsession
many requests for a sort of overview
about cancel culture as the new pet
issue for the right there's very
specific reasons why the right is
focused on it
you can also make sure you're following
us on instagram at david pakman show for
more
on all of these stories we'll take a
quick break and be back with much more
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
riots at the capitol made it very clear
that misinformation
is one of the biggest problems that our
society faces and
online filter bubbles make the problem
worse making it difficult even for
intelligent news consumers to figure out
what's true and what's not
one of our sponsors is ground news which
is a platform with a really effective
approach
to combating this problem ground news is
the world's first news comparison
platform that lets you compare
how sources from across the political
spectrum are covering a story
i use it myself i love it because it
lets me
easily see how different news outlets
are manipulating a story to fit their
own narrative
and it shows you your news blind spots
stories that your side of the political
spectrum
may not be giving attention to start out
2021
with a balanced news diet download the
ground news app for free
by going to davidpakman.com ground
the link is right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we are an audience-funded program i
would much appreciate it if you decided
if you like this
enough to support it that you grab a
membership
at joinpakman.com if you don't like this
show
keep doing what you've been doing which
is emailing me every day all right very
good let's move on
let's talk about cancel culture
understand that
we have relatively
um unforged uh we are in relatively
unforged territory
uh in the united states with the current
american right wing the american right
wing
is out of ideas the american right can't
win on policy
their health care ideas aren't popular
their economic ideas aren't popular
their social ideas are out of the 19th
century
they're totally wrong in every way on
covid
they don't accept science even on
increasingly uncontroversial topics
they can't win met when more people vote
so the right tries to suppress the vote
trump in combination with the republican
right
lost the house in 2018 lost the senate
in 2020
lost the white house in 2020 not by a
little bit by a lot as trump likes to
say
these people's ideas while clinging to
support in the united states
are the laughingstock of the world so as
we've talked about before
they make themselves victims to justify
their own existence
and because they have nothing else left
and their latest path
in so doing is talking about so-called
cancel culture and so their entire cpac
conservative political action conference
that we saw over the weekend
was crafted around this idea
the slogan was america uncanceled
trump talked about cancel culture many
of the speakers did
now i've said this before but it bears
repeating once again
cancel culture as described by the right
does not exist it's the latest ploy
met to rile people up just like
pretending
trans women in sports is the major issue
facing the united states of america
i'm not saying it's not an issue
it's just not a major issue that relates
to the lives of 99
of the country now let me be very
careful
i whenever i do this i have to issue a
disclaimer to try to save my inbox and
it still won't work but it'll help
if you were going to argue that i'm
wrong by emailing me
an article about one person that was
unfairly fired for a political view they
tweeted about
or an article about someone who was
fired because their political opinion
clashed with that of others in their
workplace or something like that
that doesn't disprove what i'm saying in
this segment
i will gladly admit that sometimes there
are unfair firings
just like sometimes there are false rape
reports
this is a country of more than 330
million people
there are examples of everything but
basing an ideology
around something insanely rare
pretending that a main policy issue
is something that statistically is
barely there is a ploy
weaponized by the right to attack the
left
to attack organizations to attack
institutions to attack
social media platforms when the right
doesn't like the decisions that they
make
cancel culture is the perfect ruse for
so many right-wing goals
right-wing politicians need to portray
themselves as victims
claiming that social media networks and
journalists in academia are all out to
get them
is the perfect way to do it religious
right folks
need to claim that their religion is
under attack
that jesus primarily is under attack
this is the perfect way to do it
right-wing politicians need to raise
money we know
that socio-cultural issues real or
imagined
doesn't matter if they exist or not are
great for fundraising
right-wing media needs to make money
outrage
porn about cancellations
of republican politicians or of
right-wing media itself or of potato
head or dr
seuss or whatever it is perfect fodder
for
ratings and importantly the right is
generally less divided on cultural
issues this goes back a long time
on economic issues you see more of a
range of views among the right in part
because of the libertarian right
in many studies including a good one
from vanderbilt university
republican positions on cultural issues
exist within a much tighter range
than they do among the left so they can
easily generate
more unity and more outrage among the
right
with these cultural issues against a
shared enemy
this is truly the perfect ruse and it's
working
now in reality what they mean by cancel
culture
is that sometimes their speech has
consequences
and it essentially describes free market
capitalism which they claim to support
and you know what that's the way things
work free speech
the first amendment usually the first
amendment doesn't even apply but they
talk about it
none of that comes with immunity from
the consequences of your speech that's
one of the elements of capitalism
that's one of the elements of markets
your speech enters
a marketplace of ideas and sometimes
there are consequences
except in very narrowly defined
situations the consequences to your
speech
are someone else's free speech which
must also be protected
what the right wants is carte blanche
to continue their policies of economic
discrimination
elitism xenophobia homophobia christian
supremacy
white supremacy whatever whatever it is
they prioritize
they want to perpetuate that and
insulate themselves
by using the term cancer culture to
intimidate the left into not criticizing
them
to intimidate the market into not having
consequences
for their speech let's not fall for it
now
give me a specific example of something
that was done wrong i will look at it
if someone didn't deserve to be fired i
will look at it and i'll tell you they
didn't deserve to be fired
but this is the way that the right is
organizing its followers
against real progressive change and
to justify their own existence absent
any
substantive policy ideas going on five
years now
the trump era was devoid of actual
policy completely
and it is now essentially uh a grievance
movement
and so often you know we talk about
projection from the right
there are these um enclaves of the right
that love to say the left is now just a
grievance movement
when i look at the left sure there's
some grievance in some circles but the
predominant
left-wing movement uh is around economic
equality accepting science and acting on
it when it comes to covid
when it comes to climate when it comes
to so many different things it's about a
15
minimum wage it's about getting health
care to people it's
there there's policy there right now for
the most part and yes on the fringes
you have the the sort of
grievance-focused elements
which i have no problem criticizing and
have done for years uh it is actually
the right
via this cancel culture meme that has
become uniquely
about victims self-victimization uh and
grievances now
next i want to look at some hilarious
examples of how the right is now going
absolutely
crazy with the cancel culture story
the right i've already given you my view
about so-called cancel culture in the
last segment and why republicans are now
doing this they have no policy
they've lost everything in the last two
years house senate white house
uh joe biden is the most popular first
month president in 28
years they are desperate and they want
to be the perpetual
unending victims now let's take a tour
through some of the funniest cancel
culture clips and claims
from the last day or two because they
now
it's sort of like a um it's like a hyena
who sends it who smells blood the hyena
notices the gazelle is a little slow on
its feet
that right rear uh uh hoof
do gazelles have hooves i think they do
that right rear hoof
uh looks a little bit not right and so
they
say the hyenas now is our opportunity
now is our opportunity and that's what
the right
is doing congressman jim jordan is now
calling for
congressional hearings on cancel culture
he sent a letter yesterday to
congressman jerry nadler
who runs the house judiciary committee
saying that cancel culture is so
dangerous so pernicious
such an existential threat that if it
goes unchallenged
every viewpoint and idea could be
cancelled
and jim jordan wants hearings that's jim
jordan
this morning on fox and friends donald
trump jr went on a cancel culture
rant which the fox and friends hosts
seemed to love at first but then you'll
hear brian kilmeade sort of try to
give don jr the wrap-up take a look at
this
there's this cancel culture trying to
cancel dr seuss now
how far are they going to take this uh
okay there's no place that they won't go
uh ainsley there's no place they won't
go
this week alone they canceled mr potato
head
uh you know this week alone they
canceled the muppets
uh you know they're they're canceling dr
seuss from reading programs i mean these
are books
i literally know the cat in the hat by
heart without the book there because i
read it so many times
to my children these things are not
racist you have oreo cookie chiming in
on trans rights
i mean what is going on i have no idea
it's absolutely insane we've
lost our minds and we're encouraging it
you know by allowing it you saw you know
the mob goes after cpac
because the stage apparently had nazi
symbolism because these guys are so
obsessed
with trying to create any link to that
and it looked like hyatt was doing a
good job but in 24 hours they too caved
to the woke mob
don thanks everything is cancellation
and notice that
each of those things that don jr
mentions are totally unrelated
the stage at cpac looked like a nazi
emblem
okay well that's totally separate from
reading material decisions made in
schools
and that's unrelated to the decisions
made by private
uh companies about the products they
want to put out now they
want you to think it's all part of the
same liberal plot and culture
it's a sort of gish gallup
conspiratorial thinking
you mentioned 10 things it's not totally
clear if they're related
but if it sort of sounds like they are
the audience hears it and goes wow that
that's quite a list of stuff but you
have to separate it out and go through
it piece by piece
here's another clip from this morning's
fox and friends they they truly seem to
have nothing to talk about
other than this talking about more
cancer culture
hey it is march 2nd it is read across
america day
it is also dr seuss's birthday and
traditionally in our country we
celebrate read across america on his
birthday because
we all grew up reading his books and
loved them but uh biden
is there is a proclamation claiming that
this is read across america day but he
is leaving out the mention
of dr seuss because of this one county
loudoun county in virginia
and they are saying that it's
controversial
and they want to cancel dr seuss yeah
they uh the researchers surveyed 50 dr
seuss books and concluded
that the 2 240 identified human
characters
there are 45 characters of color
representing two percent of the total
human population
of the 45 characters 43 exhibited
behaviors and appearances
that align with harmful and
stereotypical orient oriental
tropes so that's brian kilmeade's kind
of
fabricated outrage voice and you know
that
you by the way when fox news is
pretending to care about
literature you know it's a fabricated
issue
since literature is not a top issue for
fox news viewers
unless it plays into some other
socio-cultural outrage that they want to
generate
we know literature is not high on the
list of priorities for fox news viewers
here's another example from a few days
ago
this is from the tucker carlson
propaganda program where a lawyer
named harmeet dillon told tucker
that the left is trying to cancel women
harmeet i appreciate you're coming on
tonight so the equality act everything
is orwell
um is that is this about equality
uh it would better be named the women's
cancellation act because it looks like
cancer culture has finally come for the
female gender tucker what we're seeing
in this act is
basically a denial of science and this
is the flat earthers
taking control of the government and
using those levers of power
to elevate the rights of transgender
uh women met people who are born as men
over the rights of biological women
and it's not just conservatives who are
concerned about this tucker so there
again is the raising of the issue of
trans women in sports i i won't go into
that in detail now
because i've done two or three segments
about that over the last couple of weeks
if you're curious about my thoughts on
that you can find those clips but in
short
the fact that individually we can find
we can find instances
where we need to sort of think through
what makes sense in
certain sporting situations athletic
situations pretending that this is the
issue on the forefront of american
culture and and society
um is another one of these fabricated
outrage issues from the right
trump even jumping on board remember
trump brought up cancel culture
during that bizarre 90-minute speech at
cpac which trump himself even seemed
bored with
take a look at this and in particular
we reject cancer culture
so remember how this all works you and i
hopefully if you're like me you have a
diverse
uh set of news sources you're not just
paying attention to the news
but you're also reading history and and
reading philosophy and
other sorts of non-fiction and you sort
of have a broad view of what's going on
in the world you follow some
international
news et cetera if you only watch fox
news
and watched cpac and listen to what the
former president donald trump says
you would be under the impression that
the issues plaguing
plaguing america right now are trans
women in sports
conservatives getting suspended on
twitter potato head
dr seuss and of course fighting
communism
rather than the pandemic inequality
economics the coveted relief bill
getting people vaccinated dealing with
the climate
fixing money in politics getting
everybody healthcare that's how it works
and we know it works because you go to
cpac and you interview
random people this is the stuff that the
attendees are talking about
we're against socialism and communism so
we're mad about joe biden being here
what there's no risk of communism or
socialism in the united states
so it does work and unfortunately
it's hard to even have a shot at
deprogramming someone
if you can't even get them out of an
echo chamber where these are the issues
that are reinforced as the major issues
facing the country
so it's an uphill battle it's clear as i
as i said earlier with my hyena gazelle
analogy
they smell blood they see they see the
opportunity here
to strike on this issue of cancel
culture and they plan to
strike and strike and strike to quote
the great paula white
we will have a more coverage of this on
our instagram find us
at david pakman show and find me on
instagram
at david.pakman as well the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
i recently mentioned our partnership
with the youtube channel
nerds for humanity and the team behind
that channel has built a new website
called of the people
which you can find at of the people.us
and they're one of our sponsors today
fascinating website basically like a
yelp
for local political candidates you can
browse
and search for candidates based on
policy
location and background the key insight
from of the people is that all national
politics starts local
and by making it easier to discover and
support everyday folks
running for city council or state
assembly county commissioner
in your community you can help incubate
the talent that will become
future congressional representatives
senators
even presidents if you're a candidate
running for local office set up a
profile
on otp it's free and you can attract
exposure and donors
and everyone else go support this
grassroots platform i put a link
underneath this video
and while you're at it don't forget to
subscribe to the nerds for humanity
youtube channel
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome back to the
program michael moss
a new york times best-selling author
wrote the book salt
sugar fat new book out today is
hooked food free will and how the food
giants exploit our addictions uh so
great to have you back michael
hey nice to see you again david so in
the time since we last
spoke we've learned a lot more about the
sort of
physically addictive nature of certain
food elements we've learned about
sugar we've we've learned about other
elements but we've also learned a lot
about
um food marketing nutritionism and so
many other aspects that that operate on
a more
sort of psychological rather than
physical level talk a little bit about
sort of your general approach to this
book and and what you're talking about
when you talk about
um addiction to food yeah so i mean i
wrote the book and started researching
it because
right after stall trigger fad came out
at the end of it i was trying to be a
little optimistic and say look
ultimately we're the ones who decide
what to eat and how much and the very
first question i got was but
michael isn't this stuff you're writing
about
addictive like drugs and if so how can
we have any control over and i was like
whoa
you mean you're comparing like twinkies
to heroin i mean i was like
no way but i came full circle
in realizing and talking to experts who
coached me on this which is that
look in some ways food is even
more addictive than some drugs and
part of the reason for that is that the
companies have figured out ways to
tap into exploit if you will
our basic instincts i mean we by nature
are drawn not just to eat but to overeat
and the companies have figured that out
and turned that which was a good thing
for most of our existence
into a really treacherous thing by
making overeating
an everyday thing is um
what is the start of the chain of all of
this
is it profit motive for food giants
yeah i mean look i still don't see this
as this evil empire that intentionally
set out to
to make us overweight or otherwise ill
these are companies doing what all
companies want to do
make as much money as possible by
selling as much product as possible
and by making that product as attractive
and irresistible as as possible so
they have chemists working for them they
have marketing experts psychologists
sort of
all trained and focused on hitting our
biological instincts but also our
emotional
buttons to maximize the allure of their
products
can you talk a little bit about what
what exactly is it when you research
this
that that is most addictive is it is
sometimes said
you know the dopamine release from sugar
is similar to drugs is it what what
exactly is it
yeah so there's a few things one we are
built to sort of love food that's
inexpensive it kind of makes sense
right the least put out the least amount
of energy for the calories that you're
getting
you know the industry uses these
chemical labs to come up with new
formulations that
are shaving you know 10 cents 20 cents
off the price of a package
that excites the brain um they're
really good at variety you know
we're we by instinct are drawn toward
different kinds of foods that's why
we're able to populate different parts
of the world
with different food to eat and we're
really good at adjusting to that
you know you walk in the cereal aisle of
the grocery store
there are 200 versions of sugary starch
with that soul purpose of exciting the
brain um
we love calories right we have sensors
in our gut
also possibly in our mouth that detect
calories and food
and so the food companies have been
really good about packing
in the calories i mean compare like a
hot pocket to a stick of
celery and you get the idea of the
contrast between basic food stuff
and ultra processed foods and again the
break the brain gets
really excited by the more calories
and is much more apt to sort of put you
into that impulsive compulsive drive
where the thinking part of your brain
doesn't have a chance to
to step up and say hey wait a minute
michael i think you're going
too hard on this food it seems that at a
certain point there was a huge
evolutionary
evolutionary advantage to that in the
sense that like if you think back to
uh hunter gathering and the amount of
time
and energy spent chewing in order to
obtain a certain number of calories
and then all of a sudden you're maybe
able to you know you
you cook something and you're so which
allows you to kind of
do in advance some of the work that your
teeth and body would do
the body probably would sense that wow
one bite of this
is conferring way more calories and it
was good at a certain point
it was such an eye-opener to me spending
time with evolutionary biologists
one of whom kind of pointed out to me
look michael it's not so much that food
is addictive it's that we by nature
are drawn to eating and the companies
have changed the nature of
our food um you know you said it
absolutely body fat
was a really good thing it enabled our
brains to grow and enable us to get
through
hard time able is to have more babies
which natural selection is
all about and it's only in the last
50 years that we're sort of realizing
that having too much body fat will work
against you i had no idea but body fat
is a living thinking
organ and when you try to reduce the
amount of fat on your body
it will fight back in incredibly
diabolical ways it will send signals to
the brain
that you're hungry when you're not
hungry it will slow
down your metabolism it will make you
get more excited when you see
advertising for processed food and
cause you to want that food more than
you did
before you had that extra weight one of
the things that
michael pollan writes about in
omnivore's dilemma
is the sort of transformation by food
companies of foods into food products
taking for example the idea of like if
you just take
corn it's tough to make a lot more money
just selling corn maybe you can get a
seed that can be planted more densely so
you can sort of like
up how much you can grow in an acre but
like selling corn as corn is only going
to get you so far however
if you take corn break it down into its
component parts you can now
use corn syrup as an alternative to
sugar
you're adding calories and reducing cost
and you're extracting and taking all
these different elements
most people if they looked at a list of
ingredients would recognize
a lot of that stuff is highly processed
and probably not that good for you
and yet these products are all
incredibly popular so
so what are food companies doing in
order to make people want products that
if you're really presented with the
ingredient list
most people probably know aren't really
the best things to be eating
yeah i think one of the most important
things they're doing is
speed i learned from researchers who
study drug addiction whether it's
cigarettes alcohol or harder narcotics
that the hallmark of addiction is how
fast the substance hits
the brain because the faster it gets in
our brain the more apt we are to hit
that go button
and not respond to the smaller part of
the brain that's trying to put the
brakes on
you know us doing something we really
don't want to be doing
um and so the food companies were
ingenious
in building speed into their products
both in the factory to reduce the cost
but also
just the way we eat it and i i often
refer to these foods as convenience
foods because
a lot of them can be eaten with one hand
while you're doing
something else and that creates this
mindlessness mode um
where you're not paying attention to the
food and when you're not paying
attention to
their products they're controlling you
rather than you controlling them
so speed is this is probably the most
important
and most diabolical aspect of these
ultra processed foods
how does all of this apply to the sort
of
diets sometimes sometimes fat called fad
diets lifestyle diets that sometimes
will come in and out of favor
uh in in large part because of marketing
when it seems that
over time if you take a big picture of
you you don't really seem to need
anything so specialized it seems that
sort of uh limiting processed foods is a
good thing
generally limiting
but not necessarily completely
eliminating animal products
isn't a bad thing to me i see
profit opportunities anytime you see a
diet that requires
a lot of one thing or none of another is
my
my instinct right on that well
absolutely let me tell you about sort of
prophet i was stunned
to learn that the largest processed food
manufacturers
quietly bought up gained control over
some of our more popular dieting methods
and we're talking about
heinz buying weight watchers
slim fast atkins um
you name it south beach diet a lot of
these
brands and methods were acquired none
other than by the food companies and
then
they kind of populated the grocery store
with
diet versions of their main line
products which really weren't all that
different than the full bore calorie
version
sitting next to each other on the shelf
and sort of
counting on us to be making rational
decisions every time we go
shopping as to which of these products
to
to to to to buy and and eat and pay
attention to but
here's the thing again that sort of
relates to that relates to addiction
um the thing about and one of the
lessons from drug addiction one i think
that makes these food products
even more troublesome than drugs can be
which is that
you can't just go cold turkey you can't
just stop eating
to deal with a food eating problem we
all have to eat
and that's the slippery slope and so we
walk into the grocery store and we're
so vulnerable at times in our lives or
times of the
of the day to their marketing and their
products and these diet schemes that
look by
and large work until they stop
working which is why so many people have
trouble sticking to a diet because it's
strange and it's different and they
ultimately because the power of
memory in in escaping our eating habits
draws us back to what we were doing
before
is the uh you know most people most
people are busy people are working
people are earning a living
they have to get their kids back and
forth it can be very difficult to keep
up with
is the egg good or bad right now is
coffee good or bad is soy good about
that
is there one principle which is just
avoid
processed foods as much as possible that
is the simplest thing for people to
remember
or or or would it be something else i
think it kind of depends where you are
on the spectrum like i wrote this book
for
everybody whether you're in an eating
disorder with binging or you've got
clinical obesity
or you're at the other end where you're
just kind of like troubled by like how
much attention you have to pay the food
to stay on top of it
and not let it like you know gain
control of your of your life and i think
the overall lesson i think again a
lesson learned from the drug addiction
world is that
it really helps to have a plan no matter
what it is but
to have that plan and then execute it so
you know if you're hit by the proverbial
3 p.m
craving for a cookie what you learned
from people who've
helped people deal with drug addiction
is you've got to like at
255 you need to be working on your
your plan whether that involves getting
up and stretching or calling a friend
or having an alternative snack like a
handful of nuts in order to ward off
that craving grease
because those cravings come on so fast
that no amount of willpower is going to
help you resist them
once they hit the reward center of the
brain so that
that pre-thought no matter kind of what
your strategy is
i think is is the overall lesson i
learned in talking to two other
two addiction researchers in terms of
now uh
all of the sugar alternatives you know
sweetened with
beet sugar sweetened with monk fruit or
whatever the case may be um it is
is that really about health or is it
about profitability or is it
both the companies are in this mode now
where
more and more of us are caring about
what we put in our bodies and responding
to that by eating less of their
most problematic products the companies
are responding by
cutting back themselves sugar fat but
also adding
things um to their products like protein
or fiber you know on the notion that
that
might help reduce the cravings we get
for those products
sugar is really interesting to me and
i'm you know
and and the science is still new on this
and
and i wouldn't and i wouldn't bet on it
at this point but
there is concern that this move by the
industry to
replace reduce sugar by replacing it
with
fake non-caloric sweeteners
could be really problematic i mean think
about it
you know you taste something sweet your
brain is expecting
calories but your gut doesn't get those
calories
you know it's quite possible that
something will go haywire with your
metabolism so i mean if you're using a
diet soda to
really resist you know drinking a full
calorie soda and that works for you
you know nutrition was to say okay go
for it but
overall i think it's really troubling
that the companies are moving around the
entire
grocery store now trying to reduce
the sugar level but keeping that
sweetness by using these
sweet sweet fake sweeteners non-caloric
ones
without us knowing enough about the
science to be really confident in how
that's going to work in our bodies
well that that seems to be the crux of
of the sort of nutritionism
approach that you can you can
essentially break a food down to a
certain number of calories
grams of fat uh amount of vitamin c or
whatever and what what you would sort of
get to is
a pill that has the same statistics as
broccoli
and assuming that it will do the same
thing for you when the whole food really
has something to it that may be beyond
mathematical identification for lack of
a better term
yeah i think that's so perspective and
it's perceptive of you and
and i'll tell you the story in that you
know that you know the nutrition facts
box on products the labels you say that
fine print on the back of the label
not all of us can you know read it or
even understand it right
i had no idea that that fact box was the
creation of none other than the
processed food industry
right as a way of warding off our
concerns
about their products because in some
ways one of our basic instincts too is
to love
information and kind of be placated one
scientist calls us
infos and and the reality is when we
turn to that facts box and try to like
parse out these nutrient parts of this
food that isn't really food
anyway in the totality we get lulled
into thinking
all that data must be really great and
this is okay
for us to eat but the nutrition facts
box is
is is a bit of treachery in and of
itself
no no no question about it the new book
out today
is hooked food free will and how the
food giants exploit our addictions
we've been speaking with the book's
author michael moss michael always a
pleasure speaking to you
great to see you and talk to you too
david the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so this is a pretty interesting we've
been wondering
what direction fox news is going to take
in the post-trump era will they go more
in the direction
of the non-trump republicans the
direction of people like
mitt romney and liz cheney kind of going
back to the george w
bush era will fox news go fully back
in on trump or trumpian elected
officials the sort of marjorie taylor
green
lauren beaubert madison cawthorne
direction and there's all sorts of
considerations one way or the other
but ultimately we're going to have to
wait and see um
yesterday morning the morning after
donald trump's
bizarre and dishonest 90-minute long
speech to cpac
the conservative political action
conference the fox and friends
morning show hosts were sort of
gleefully
repeating donald trump's clever lies
about
having won the 2020 election now it's
sort of like a lie
ception type of thing one of the people
they invited on to talk about trump's
speech
is fox news host pete heg seth now heg
seth was also a speaker at cpac
i'm going to play this clip for you and
what what i can't totally tell here is
clearly when pete heg seth the guy on
the right of the screen
reminisces about donald trump's cpac
speech lie about winning
uh the presidential election a third
time pete heggseth is definitely being
serious
when steve ducey repeats it it's less
clear that ducey is saying it as
truth it sort of seems like ducey is
repeating it
as what it was that trump alleges
um but pete seth is definitely serious
about it take a look
that's what they wanted to hear they
wanted to hear that there's going to be
a republican
in the big chair at the white house in
four years yeah he went on to say i
think right after that
we may just have to beat them for the
third time right an allusion to 2016
in 2020
there you go exactly everyone in the
crowd got it right away um
though it was all about you talked a lot
about the borders so yeah i mean
it seems like steve ducey is just kind
of like repeating what the claim
is ainsley earhart and brian kilmeade
just look kind of baffled as pete seth
was saying it but at least
for now at the bare minimum fox news
is allowing if maybe not yet fully on
board with perpetuating the lie
that joe biden didn't really win the
2020 presidential election
this is a really big editorial decision
uh to make for fox news
will fox news for the next four years
be based on the lie that donald trump
actually won the 2020 election
will fox news definitively move away
from that idea
what i think is most likely is that fox
news will sort of play with it they'll
sort of play coy and what i mean by that
is
their opinion people in the evenings
will continue to kowtow to the idea
that the election wasn't really fair
their news people
will report on the fact that quote many
people believe
donald trump actually won the 2020
election
and it'll just more or less stay in the
ether
without fox news ever taking a
definitive and clear
editorial position as a as a broadcast
outlet
and if they're asked about it fox
executives will be able to say hey you
know listen
each of our shows each of our hosts
they're allowed to have their own
opinions
they make editorial decisions blah blah
blah that's my best guess
as to what we will see on fox as of
right now and it'll serve a few purposes
one is it allowed them to sort of hedge
and and have something that all flavors
of right wingers can find that they
agree with
it's also probably a way legally
speaking to avoid further lawsuit
trouble
they won't have guests on attacking
dominion voting systems specifically
but they'll generally have some hosts
continue to put out the vague idea
that many people believe biden didn't
really win in a completely fair way
and that way they'll be able to placate
just about anybody who's looking for
something that is marginally less crazy
than newsmax and oan
if you expect something different let me
know
i would very much love to hear from you
donald trump gave an interview
to fox news host steve hilton after that
90-minute long cpac speech
on sunday evening and it was actually
interesting because steve hilton did
attempt
to confront donald trump about the riots
now if you watched trump's cpac speech
even though it was 90 minutes long
and it covered a lot of topics cancel
culture how trump really won the
election
how trump is so popular you know all
this stuff there wasn't a single word
about the january 6th riots at the u.s
capitol
that donald trump incited during trump's
90-minute
cpac speech so let's look at some clips
here
from this interview with steve hilton
here is hilton
asking donald trump about the reports
that he was enjoying watching the riots
on tv on january 6th
and trump sort of weirdly tries to deny
that he was watching it but in so doing
he admits he was watching it exactly as
was reported take a listen to this
that when that was unfolding you were
watching
and actually you you liked what you were
seeing because you felt that it was your
people
fighting for you um do you get how bad
it was
and is there anything looking back on it
now that you would have done differently
that day
well that's incorrect reporting at first
i wasn't watching tv
i turned it on later on when i heard
about it and did a lot of moves
so if you listen to what donald trump
said i wasn't watching tv
i turned it on when i heard about it
well yeah trump heard about it
while the riots were going on that's
when he turned it on it's a very strange
kind of like denial where he's actually
saying the reports are correct
and then trump says he quote did a lot
of moves i don't even know what that
means but this answer
is so silly it's so obviously a lie
clearly donald trump watched the riots
on tv just like everybody at the white
house was watching them
it would be crazy if trump wasn't
watching the riots like what do we think
trump was doing
we're to believe that trump went to the
rally at which he incited the riots
went to the white house everybody at the
white house every news station
is covering the riots tweeting about the
riots etc etc mike pence is being
evacuated
and trump is like what is trump doing
what would he possibly even be doing
other than following what it is that's
going on so of course trump was watching
and he's lying
trump later in the same segment went on
to try to blame nancy pelosi for the
riots somehow
but before doing that donald trump
falsely claims that hundreds of
thousands of people
were at his january 6th rally watching
him speak no but
we actually i requested i said look this
rally is going to be bigger than anyone
thinks
because everybody i see said oh we're
going to be at the rally we're going to
be at the rally
and it had a it was i think the largest
crowd that i've ever spoken before and
i've spoken
very big crowds hundreds of thousands of
people and more than that
hundreds of thousands of people and
more than that he still can't stop lying
about the same things that he's been
lying about for years
he's learned nothing and then okay now
on to blaming nancy pelosi
they took that number from what i
understand they gave it to the people at
the capitol which is controlled by
pelosi
and i heard they rejected it because
they didn't they could look good
so you know that was a big mistake do
you i just want to know how you
feel about it now do you do well
i think people want to hear you say that
i i don't know
i hate to say i think it's terrible i
hate to see it
i will tell you that it's very
interesting however
when you see washington burning and when
you see seattle birding and portland
burning and all these other places
burning with
antifa and the radical left nothing
seems to happen nobody seems
to be bothered by that so trump shifting
to
antifa of course the january sixth riots
happened when trump was president so did
all of those other things that donald
trump
mentioned there trump then is asked are
you happier
without twitter and trump says well you
know i do have a lot of free time now
because i don't have to worry about
avoiding
spelling and grammar mistakes in my
tweets
and he also mentions that it's not just
that he's happier without twitter
his poll numbers are higher than they've
ever been
for him or anyone else i guess he's
saying here you interpret if you can
another report which may or may not be
true that actually since
um you've been you've been stopped from
using twitter
you're actually happier to be off
twitter and i'm just wondering whether
you know the impact of your speech today
not being on twitter there's a sort of
trump 2.0 where there's kind of less is
more strategy that actually might be
something you want to see well it could
be i mean i
have much more time i can now speak to
you a little bit and
i can do things that frankly when you're
tweeting
it does take up time and you want to
make it perfect because if you make a
spelling mistake or you put a comma
in the wrong location they go wild he
doesn't know this or
so you know you want to make it good you
want to make it but i will tell you
i do have much more time uh i my poll
numbers are high
you know i think they're the highest
they've ever been it's very interesting
i had when i was tweeting and you i know
you about tweeting too but i'm telling
you it's
sort of very cool i had a lot of people
saying i love them
we love our president but i wish you
wouldn't tweet it's
true so that is that is really something
else
another strange interview my
honest assessment after hearing this
interview and also watching the sunday
cpac speech is that trump
seems to be kind of going through the
motions but he seems very deflated in
reality
sort of desperate to have relevance in
political capital again
he wants to be king maker for 2022
that's why he's announced
that he's now fundraising and you can
donate to him
to his pack to help people
get elected or re-elected in 2022 and it
seems as though how well that goes will
be a big factor as to whether he runs in
2024
i have no idea whether he will or won't
run in 2024
but increasingly seeming deflated and
like he's not even really sure
that he wants to stay in politics we'll
see what ultimately happens and i don't
know if we're going to see
too many more upcoming interviews from
donald trump we have a voicemail
number that you can call and leave me a
voicemail you can call it any time of
day
to david 2192davidp is the voicemail
here's i've gotten a lot of messages
about progressives and cryptocurrency
lately
here's one such voicemail inquiring
about exactly that take a listen
hey david uh this is hubian i had a
question man
um so i'm pretty heavy into the crypto
space
i am a progressive but i found that
there is a large libertarian
group in crypto normally and one of
their big arguments
is that our traditional finance is going
to collapse because we're just spending
a ton of money
and inflation is going to go haywire i
i have my reservations about that
position and
i would really appreciate you sort of
just maybe maybe doing a deeper analysis
on inflation generally in the economy as
with regard to how our government prints
money
i think it would be very insightful as
usual and would be very helpful to me
because then i just send them a link
and just say here um consider this so
thanks man i hope y'all do i've been
watching you for like over a half decade
now it's kind of crazy to think about
but thanks man
bye yeah these are good topics i mean
the thing about inflation
is um the first first of all the term
printing money at this point is so
antiquated i mean
we're really the government's not not
printing money we're talking about
digitally
creating money which you might say that
that's not that different than
than bitcoin and you would be right the
difference is it's a government
that is digitally creating us dollars
rather than um you know an algorithmic
process
with bitcoin that uh is is creating it
um i am not big into the progressive
anti-cryptocurrency
movement i think that there are concerns
about cryptocurrency just like there are
concerns
with government-backed currencies the in
the the inflation
spiral people have been proven wrong i
mean
they've just been proven wrong the
united states if you go back to tarp and
the stimulus under obama in 2009
um the the money supply has continued to
increase in the united states what do
you think stimulus is fundamentally
and we've seen very well controlled
inflation in the united states
uh additionally our understanding of
modern monetary theory
continues to show that that the sort of
uh doom and gloom
inflation spiral claims are uh
the predictions just aren't bearing out
the same people have been making the
same predictions for a really long time
at some point we may get more inflation
in the united states but that's sort of
like the people who are constantly
predicting a crash
eventually they'll be right because
that's the way uh
capitalist economies work it's booms and
busts and at some point there there's
going to be a crash
some of the other criticisms of
cryptocurrency like for example
you know the energy usage of bitcoin
mining okay yeah i understand that
but traditional banking also has a
massive
energy and carbon footprint um
the the physical location components of
that banking industry
have huge environmental implications and
the the
the other element of this that i think
is interesting is
as we switch over um
to alternative energy the bitcoin can be
mined with renewable energy as well so
that one has never really felt felt
great
to me the general assessment
that bitcoin could collapse at any time
and it's only as good as people's demand
or
interest in in holding it yeah i'm
absolutely that's absolutely true
and i've made no secret that i guess at
this point it's four and a half years
ago
i bought an amount of bitcoin that at
the time was sort of reasonably
calibrated to my financial situation
it's obviously gone 10x since then my
assessment of the
volatility of bitcoin hasn't changed
it's just at this point it seems like
it's here to stay enough that i want it
to be a slice of my portfolio
and it's done well so far it may not in
the future that wouldn't justify its
existence one way or the other
and it's really up to everybody to
decide what for for themselves
sort of what financial decisions make
sense but
uh so so i guess my takeaway is there
are good reasons to be skeptical of all
sorts of financial instruments
the stock market bitcoin currency
exchange whatever
um when i see particularly
um sort of hyperbolic arguments from
progressives
only applied to crypto when they could
apply elsewhere as well
it doesn't really inspire me to say yeah
that's exact that that's
more give me more of that please i think
that's where i am we've got a great
bonus show for you today we will talk
about the elizabeth warren bernie
sanders new wealth tax
proposal we will also talk about a
landmark voting rights
case before the supreme court we will
talk about former french president
nicolas sarkozy
being found guilty of corruption and
much more
so do yourselves a favor and me grab
a membership at joinpakman.com you'll
get instant access to the bonus show
and then you can join us there in mere
moments
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are influencing the
news you read
download the ground news app for free at
davidpakman.com
ground of the people is a new platform
matching local campaigns with supporters
and donors from across the country
sort of like a yelp for local candidates
you can filter by policy and location
and you can support the next generation
of leaders check it out at
of the people.us